alright Leonardo is with us in New
Jersey
hey Leonardo how are you hey guys thank
you so much for taking my call my
girlfriend Alyssa says hi and you are
her favorite right so my question is
from a leader standpoint how do I start
effectively communicating to my West
Point peers / classmates about investing
living that furry and learning about
finances so they can avoid becoming a
part of the 57 percent of military
families who experience financial
hardships before we graduate ah it's
really difficult to answer questions for
people that aren't asking them and stick
your nose in other people's business
it's just very hard the only thing you
can do is the way you live your life and
you can talk about your experience and
say this is what I'm doing and then that
can create some conversations and some
questions but the but just to start
saying well the military has this
problem and 57% of the families and you
know the number one cause of loss of
security clearance and military's
financial problems which is true by the
way
a third largest reason for dishonorable
discharge is financial irresponsibility
which is true by the way we work with
the military all the time it's it's a
rampant problem just under the surface
financial problems and so yeah as an
officer our potential officer you are
the chance to influence some of the
folks in your charge hopefully on the
area of finance and so that's how we end
up teaching in the military all the time
is through people like that but in
general regardless of military or not
it's just your group of friends your
group appears how do you influence them
yeah I mean you're exactly right I was
thinking the same thing I'm like
obviously being a good friend being in
people's lives and when struggles come
up in life usually people turn to their
friends so if they know that you're
intentional with your money you do
something that's kind of different than
everyone else when they start to have
issues you're probably gonna be the one
that they come to and and talk to but
yeah
forcing conversation
we're trying to force people to change
who are not willing to change or don't
want to change I weren't even asking its
kind of yeah or even that - yeah it's
kind of I don't answer questions for
people that don't ask them not anymore
but I will tell my story that's it I
think that that's one of the most
powerful things you can do because it
lends itself probably to interesting
questions and people oh really well
that's why why did you do that how did
you do that and it starts that
conversation and it's not a shaming
thing like you need to do what I did
it's just like this is what I'm doing
yep and man here's what I'm experiencing
and I used to be freaked out and now I
don't have any credit cards and I don't
and I've got money and it's so cool it's
a it's a really neat experiment I'm
doing and you know and so they may want
to know more they may not want to know
more at that point and that's where you
are so hey good question thank you for
joining us